hello everyone and welcome to round
seven of the 2018 bill chest first of
all it's an eco gear geodesy versus
Peter Svidler Peter Svidler is having a
pretty decent tournament so far but Nico
did not win a single game so far and the
only draw he had so far was against the
world champion Magnus Carlsen
now before we check out this game and
it's I'm pretty sure it's the most
romantic game that was played so far in
this tournament kind of reminds me of
some of my games not not because because
of the quality of the game but I'll tell
you later why before we check out the
game let's check out some of the photos
as there was a rest day so the players
were on a boat trip so here is a very
nice photo by Leonard totes also from
the official bill chess festival website
there will be a link in the description
below
that's Maxine mashaallah Grove and you
know I really think it's a very lovely
photo you know shooting a Frenchman
through a wine glass very very fitting
and then we have a very nice photo of
David navara and as you can see our
mammoth yard is behind him even if you
don't recognize its mama dro you can
always recognize you know the outfit
mama dro will be wearing so here we have
a photo of all the participants all of
them besides Magnus Carlsen
I don't think Magnus Carlsen was a
present at this trip for some reason I
don't know why either have the 5%
participants and I don't know if you
knew the the official bill chest
festival has two commentators two
official commentators one of them is
Daniel King and the other one is present
in this photo so for the photo challenge
can you guess who the who the second
official commentator for the bill chess
festival 2018 is in this photo so there
you have it
best of luck to everyone now let's check
out this game we have E 4 C 5 this is
still in defense Knight to f3 d6 d4 and
C captures on d4 Knight captures Knight
to f6 Knight to c3 and we have a 6
wheeler goes for the knight or variation
and this Wheeler said in an interview
after this game he doesn't really
consider himself a knight or player
writer he does but from from the from
White's perspective so Bishop e3
we have we have e 6 g 4 and now h 6 and
here spoiler says that some 20 years ago
he did analyze this position thoroughly
and he knows what what should be played
here
he says f 3 was played here F 4 was
played here a G better - G - was played
here H 3 was played here but did the
move Nico plays he thought it wasn't
possible here here Nico played h4 and
already sweedler knew that he ran into
into some sort of preparation and ok he
played e5 and here Nico says that it was
very fortunate for Saylor that he chose
the e5 move even though he was not
prepared for this variation because it
appears to be the strongest move for
black and also that Nico didn't really
prepare for the e5 move Knight to a5 and
now comes g6 and here all all hell
breaks loose so what do you do here
the knight is under attack you can move
the knight that's true but it's it's
definitely not recommended Knight
captures on h6 can be played Bishop
captures on h6 can be played the g5 can
be played now let's see what happens if
g5 is played
if g5 then this is what black had in
mind H captures on g5 and now Knight
back to g3 so what do you do here if you
capture with the rook if rook captures
it then Bishop captures it's no problem
attacking the denied ended the rook and
if G captures on h4 then you get Bishop
to g5 again you cannot capture the
knight here because the pawn is pinned
you will capture the rook and always
well here after black defense you will
capture back the pawn and a black black
is better here
so after g6 Nico decided to play Knight
captures on h6 we have Bishop captures
on h6 and now you have to make a
decision either you want to play g5
immediately and win back the piece or
you want to play H captures Bishop
captures Bishop and after rook captures
only then push g5 it's interesting if
you push g5 immediately then Knight to
g4 is coming pawn captures Bishop Knight
captures on e3 f captures on e3 and now
rook captures on h6 and it seems like a
white didn't really do that well he has
a double D pawn but actually at the
engine really
first this line for white because after
Queen to f3 your queen is nicely played
Bishop is coming to see for your free to
Castle queenside rook is coming to f1 so
a better position for white as it seems
but okay after Bishop captures on h6
Nico first played Bishop captures on h6
and now a suitor doesn't recapture the
bishop immediately the g4 point is
attacked twice it so first arrives at
Bishop captures on g4 we have point to
f3 and now Bishop captures on f3 Queen
captures on f3 and now rook captures on
h6 and here we have Queen side castles
Swigert continues the knife to c6 and
okay the position is pretty much equal
White is a bit better in development but
black is up upon and here you could play
a lot of things you could simply
continue developing with white or
whatever you want to do is simply brush
up to h3 maybe we want to defend the h4
pawn first Queen g3 Queen f2 and then
only go by short h3 but here
Nico goes for the absolute quick as the
development which is why this is a very
enjoyable game he wants to get this rook
to f1 as then the knight will be attack
twice it will be very hard to defend
this night and the night will be unable
to move because there the f7 point will
be under attack so he moves the bishop
with with with tempo Bishop captures on
a6 so what do you do here the best move
of course is to capture the bishop so
sweedler does it Bishop captures arrow
characters on a six and now comes rook
h2f one with a double attack on the
night so you will either defend the
night or you have to give back the piece
it's not really a piece sacrifice so how
do you defend of course if you move the
night then Queen captures on f7 will be
checkmate everyone can see that what
happens if you try g5
now the rook is defending the knight and
for example H captures Knight moves and
now you are forcing White's to capture
with the pawn and then you you've given
back the piece and also stopped the
attack but here what would go in with
Knights to d5 and now after a pretty
force variation rook captures on a to
Knight captures on f6 with check rook
captures
Queen captures Queen captures rook
captures we have looked one check King
d2 rope capture scheme captures its
actually white who'd be up the exchange
with an easily winning game so after
this rook h2f once wiggler goes for
Knights to D for attacking Nico's Queen
and trying to force him to capture on f6
but here Nico tries once again to go
all-in as he is tired of losing every
game he goes rook captures on d4 so what
do you do here of course you have to
capture the rook in capture some
DeForest played and lonely now comes
Knight to d5 wooded triple attack
against Blacks f6 Knight of course you
still cannot move the knight as Queen
captures on f7 would still be checkmate
sauce with her plays rook captures on a2
we have Knight captures on f6 with check
King to f8 and now King Tubby 1 Nico
keeps the rook back rook to a5 and the
now comes Queen to f4 attacking us
withers rope on h6 and here we have king
to g7 King g7 is a beautiful move by
sweedler really an amazing move because
you really have to see that Knight to g4
is okay too
at the face now there's a double attack
against the h6 rook and also a double
attack against the f7 pawn and here you
have to see that rook captures on h4
saves black as you can even allow Queen
captures on f7 after King comes to h8
now there's no good continuation for
white the black will simply enjoy being
an exchange up after Queen captures on
g6 rook to g5 attacking the knight and
the Queen and after Queen moves of
course you have to capture and after
captures rook g2 you you're simply
enjoying being an exchange up
so after this King to g7 of course
Knight to g4 was not played by Nico a
rather he played B for attacking the
rook rook to b5 and here not a critical
moment in the game or anything just the
witch-king to c1 a Nico could still
perhaps continue playing this game you
cannot capture here because the rook is
needed to guard the g5 square as you've
seen in the previous variation but even
though you know the evaluation goes in
blacks favor here it's always somewhat
easier to attack them to defend so
probably you know it would still be
playable
after work to be 5/9 the d fight was
played by Nikko attacking and now
defending the b5 the before porn and
also creating an attack against the f7
pawn and here sweedler simply took the
opportunity and played the absolute best
move f5 now there is no longer a target
on f7 and also if you capture here then
the night becomes unguarded so very nice
you know taking advantage of this Knight
to d5 move and here there's a really no
good way to continue the attack for
white shirt there are probably some
creative ideas here but Nikko goes for
each captures on f5 he continues
sacrificing material and he keeps
pushing for for something rook captures
on d5 Svidler calls his bluff grabs the
knight on d5 and here there's really no
good way to continue if you capture on
g6 good ideas of coming to to f7 then
Queen to e7 of course you will not
capture on g6 and white has no more
attacking ideas black is simply upper
rook
so after rook captures on d5 Nico tried
f6 this game with Czech we have King to
h7 now comes Queen to e4 attacking the
rook on d5 rook to h5 now the rooks are
nicely connected on the fifth rank Queen
to e6 in hopes of infiltrating which
Queen to f7 but after Queen to f8 Queen
to d7 was played with check spitter
played King to h6 and it was in this
position that Nico gear goddess resigned
the game unmoved 28 as there are no more
resources you know he's all out of fuel
he's down a whole rook and there's
really no point in continuing playing
disposition so yeah now it's very
interesting you know in positions like
these after rook to b5 he wanted to
continue attacking but a slow move a
king to c1 would perhaps allows whittler
you know a lot of different paths paths
to choose from and perhaps you know he
would also give Nico a chance you have
to sometimes give your opponent a chance
to make as many mistakes as possible
nice to d5 allows this breakthrough with
f5 the absolute best most fielder played
it and it was all over so and yeah
that's what I meant in the beginning the
widest
mine's me of a lot of my games because I
would also you know just attack attack
attack and it would work you know when
you start playing chess you will not
face a very strong opponents and then
you will defeat them with such attacking
radius but then you will face a strong
defender and you know at some point in
the game you will not be able to attack
anymore you will have to you know play a
slow move maybe you know turn defensive
or something but if you you know keep
pushing keep on attacking you will just
run out of resources and your opponent
will crush you which is what happened in
this game so that's the game gear guys
versus fiddler from round seven of the
2018 bill chess festival I do hope you
enjoyed it and that you're enjoying the
coverage of this series so far I would
like to thank Steve Christians for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous videos er
think all for watching and I will see
you probably with another game from the
round seven of the bill chess festival
as it's quite an interesting round I
believe all three games are very
interesting so either I will show one
more or even two more and then we're
gonna check out the standings after
round seven I think I'll end I'll see
you soon